Song.
That's what we do.
We got a whole box of OG makeup,
and Mike is here,
so we're gonna go through it.
Good. In yours
while improving the appearance of texture,
suppleness, and signs of aging.
Bring it on.
Little goes a long way. So good.
Well, that does feel really smooth.
Oh, this is nice.
Yeah, it feels really good.
Kind of bouncy, a little bit under my eye.
Oh, yeah,
that's nice. Okay,
so now we got our base on.
Starting off now with this.
Hi,
George. Hi. Bronzy.
Oh, I love that.
It's like a moisturizer. Wow,
that blends really? Yeah,
that's amazing.
I wanna do it good. What?
There is, I think. No,
just playing.
Ja,
Ja.
So moisturizing.
Yeah, just keep it.
So here's the mascara.
This nice mascara.
Haha.
A
pink.
It's like that.
Я знову останню